I'm sorry what was your name
uh my real name was Amy
but everybody calls me Center they call
you sinner yeah how'd you get that name
um my friends back home used to call me
Sarah I just come up with the name and
everyone started calling me that and it
kind of stuck to me everybody's back
home uh Panama City Florida
tell me how you grew up you had mom and
dad
um no I was adopted by my grandmother
and my grandfather and
after they were married for 42 years
they divorced so I lived with my granny
and I got pregnant at a young age
um
I had her before too much or let's see I
had her in May and our birthday is in
October I turned 15. you turned what 15
15. yep
so
that's kind of how I
um childhood went a little bit
um I was I was a kid raising a kid I
left home when she um was learning how
to crawl
and never went back so would you leave
home
um to move well I moved in with my
boyfriend
and um
we started raising her alone without you
know I felt if I was old enough to have
a child I could move out on my own
so I went and we got the child yeah and
I was 14.
and
I moved out and just started we moved by
a titty bar so of course that was what
kind of people I was around and
ah
you know it's kind of crazy
you've been kind of in the streets ever
since yeah I never went back home
never asked to go back home I just I
liked it
because my granny was kind of cuckoo
anyways you know she was old she had
like all Alzheimer's or whatever
and um
she was you know I should have been
there watching her too you know but
I have a little baby now
and the struggle's real now for sure man
because I'm on my own and I didn't get
no kind of Child Support I didn't get
nothing like that so I took care of her
all by myself and
okay you're 24 and I'm a grandmother now
how old are you I am 38. I'll be 39 this
year
I've heard you in school
um I went to like eighth grade in School
because when she was born
I was not leaving her at home with my
credit as he asked grandmother
so
yeah your parents lost you for what
reason
um well my mom gave me it for adoption
whenever I was like three
because they feel me in the yard having
seizures
and my mom was a really bad crackhead
she
skipped my mom she did smoked crack
and [__] years constantly that was
her life
so
I didn't want that to be
part of my life at all
and my grandparents adopted me
and I never really knew my mom until
they released my mom three years early
from prison
she was terminally ill
and she came home
with us and that was the most and she
passed away
like nine months later and she was 42.
that's that was what I know of my mom
you have one child
no I have three I have four actually but
one passed away
where your three kids in Florida
with your grandmother oh no well my one
daughter's grown
and whenever I went to prison in 2000
and not or yeah 2009
[Music]
um
I filled out a bunch of stuff that had
happened
you know to him
by his dad
like the the I guess they did like a
test they you know they check your kid
out whatever well they said that someone
had
hold on can I tell these people to shut
up they're gonna walk away
so they said oh sorry they said that um
someone had
fingered his balls that's what they told
me
and
um I freaked out you know what I mean
like I didn't I didn't even think
someone would think like that you know
what I mean up to a little boy
so um
before I left for prison I I found a
couple that couldn't have children and
stuff that lived in Tallahassee
and I gave him what four adopters until
I felt that was the best thing for him
because these people seem like really
good people they didn't seem like some
weirdos or not that they were young they
were vibrant they were happy
and I felt like
he would be better off because for one
I'm an addict and now I know who your
daddy is
garbage you will never be around him
again
if I can help it and I figured that was
the only way I could stop it
so
that's what I did
it hurts me every day
but I know it was better off for him
than to be around
a needle Junkie and someone trying to
mess with him up his butt because that's
just got disgusting
that's uncalled for
and that's just inhumane
and didn't like it so I was going to
make sure that never happened
and I did
and I wish I would have chose different
because I would be indifferent
Society you know a different
atmosphere of Life what's your biggest
regret
is not being a mother to my kids
that's my biggest regret is not being a
good mom to my children
but when he's 18
I took my identification on Facebook
and um
I told him and I named the Facebook page
mommy loves you and it shows my picture
and it showed well at the time it showed
my phone number and my address and
everything because I did have a place
and um I was living with my friend and
he was sick and he told me
that whenever he passed that his home
and his truck was behind it you know
what I'm saying so I stayed there for a
while but I couldn't then he wanted to
start having sex and
he was like 70 and I was like never
forget the house I really live outside
so that's what um
so I moved from there so there's the
wrong address and everything but the
Facebook page was
mommy loves you son and it shows my
picture my identification
and um just just tells me how much I
love him
two I really miss him
but I just think that was I mean I was
adopted so I don't see I didn't I just
still don't see nothing wrong in it if
you're not
mentally sorry my hand is this just
happened last week my hand
s I'll tell you about that but
um if you're not
um physically mentally or I was
physically able
kinda maybe but mentally after all that
I was not able to take care of him
obviously because I let something like
that happen you know he never told me
that anyone touched him he never acted
out of what out of the way
you know what I'm saying hey
never said that to me which of course I
never said to him like I did my girls if
anyone ever touches you down there or
your boobs you go straight to Mommy or
if you see and I mean they can do what
the police were or you go straight to
the police and you tell them
don't ever not tell me that because
that's something that they're not
supposed to do is touch you under your
panties you know that's what I always
told my kids that so
but I didn't tell him that because he's
a little boy and
I just didn't think people you know
especially his own family
and he was never
um
babysited he never never but by his
grandmother so
I would never let him go off the babysit
with some stranger or nothing
so that's the story of my son
I missed him his name was David Grant or
his name is David Grant
and um
if you watch us on YouTube son I love
you and I'm waiting for you to turn 18.
mommy's still here waiting
and that's all I got to say about him
what is your drug now
um my target choice is heroin
which means Fentanyl
um I really don't like the fit in
fentanyl but I use it when I can't find
my heroin because
um
you know
but I don't like the the FED fit and all
because it just makes me pass out
you know I'm not and then
everything gets stolen or but from what
I've heard once you try fentanyl you
never heroin doesn't do the trick
anymore yeah well I mean I've been doing
um I finally found me someone to get my
heroin from
but um
I just
[Music]
I wish I didn't do none of that crap but
I don't know what to say now
you've been making money
um
well I got an accident no five
and
um
they took my spleen
I lacerated my liver I approaching my
lung
[Music]
um
I have a titanium rod in my leg
and
um my L2 burst and my spine so I'm
disabled so I get like a social security
check
but that don't that's not enough money
to for a person to live on buy gas for a
vehicle
buy insurance take care of everything
so
I mean I do whatever yeah
whatever
whatever yeah I understand
I mean
I know people get the point or get the
picture
but I try not to let that happen too
often what does that do to you
emotionally
just mean it's it's degrading it's
hurtful
and I don't like being like that
at all
yeah
yeah and I definitely don't want much
you order
knowing that lifestyle of me
because
I don't want them to be like that
because you know they're gonna say well
if Mommy does it then it's okay
or if whatever you know they see us
doing it then they think it's okay to do
it too or even hear about it
and
my my 24 year old
she um
she's a hot mess
a real bad mess
but but wait
well she already been in prison once for
having
um cocaine and marijuana
and uh let's see like in January I think
she got busted again
and they found 28 grams of
methamphetamine and five grams of heroin
a few following your mom's footsteps uh
definitely not
because I
I would not have been
um taking my boyfriend's charges because
I'm pretty sure that's what happened
you know I always said uh [__] you take
your own charge because I'm uh are you
following in your mom's footsteps
um
no
I don't get down like that I'll hug you
and me and talk to him and you know what
I'm saying but I definitely stick to my
own kind
every once in a while
but I I keep it stick to my own car my
own kind of my own color
what's your biggest fear now
I'm getting killed out here on these
streets
I mean I have a vehicle and stuff and
that's where I stay at it's in my truck
but um
if they if they really want to hurt me
it
it's just a glass away you know so
but
I try to stay low-key
like you don't see my vehicle I rode the
bus every year my stuff's parked which I
got to put a battery in it and that's
what I'm gonna do is get a battery this
morning
and um
I'm putting it
so
[Music]
you have no family to
um I have a brother
and he's he's on the I'm better than you
list
because he he went back he went to
prison a long long time ago and it
totally changed his life
like he is he's he's my role model now
and he does very good um he's an
electrician he used to run or I don't
know I know last time I asked he was
running a crew of eight
you know and for you to have that
lifestyle and totally change and be
a totally different person like someone
I would
that's my brother you know like um and
we got the same mom and stuff
it does give me hope
um
but I really don't get in trouble like I
know I have my little addiction that I
do but I do everything private I say to
myself I don't have to I like that like
the boy that called me over here I just
met him yesterday you know what I'm
saying so I don't know nobody I keep it
like that because
if once I start having friends
then they start seeing what I got they
start stealing my stuff and
I start wanting to murder people
and I I just I just have to say to
myself hey this is all materialistic you
can buy it again you know you do
whatever
so but I really have um thought about
doing some really harmful things to
these people were stealing from me
been your lowest point
um
um about there now this is my lowest as
I love about the lowest I've ever been
this is the lowest I've ever been
I mean it's not it's not too bad because
I mean the missions and all the people
Help Us
man that's very grateful but
I feel like because I'm white
and it's black lives matter so much now
nobody else matters but damn they're the
number one is the only ones and
everybody else can get [__] kinda is
how I feel
and
who who made these black people
US country us us Indians us people like
that you know what I'm saying who
brought them from Africa or wherever the
[__] they were from
to help them
we didn't brainwave her for them to take
over
you know and that's what they're trying
to do and it's going to be a really
sickening world
because they are nasty
that's what I gotta say about that
dear friends
not too many maybe one or two I still
talk to my friends back all myself yes I
got a few friends back home
you think there's a chance you'll be in
this situation for the rest of your life
no
what's going to change
um something
's going to change I won't find me a
rich man and marry him
that's what's gonna change
yeah that's what it's going to be well
find me a rich man
probably a little older than me you know
marrying and
then it'll be all right
because I
I mean I went to I went to prison
and got a little GED thing so I can do I
can get a job and stuff now probably
but I'm disabled I have really bad PTSD
um I have really bad anxiety and Trauma
of all the trauma
and um being beat on be it like my ex I
used to hold me down and beat the [__]
out of me like
the guy that run the little part that we
were in I mean we had it we lived in a
trailer he ran the little trailer park
he brought me glasses to my door and
told me he didn't want me walking to the
trailer park like that that's how bad my
eyes were but just go be where we had
beat on me and stuff
and um the last time we did that to me
there was blood all over the
refrigerator there's blood all over the
floor I looked like an exorcist walking
to the house because he was like 260
pounds to my
150. oh I had weight only then yeah
and
I told him I said here put your hands on
me again I said this is your last chance
I said I'm going to call the cops to you
you know and three days later before we
left for work he got ill with me and
like shoved me
I said there it is and I picked up the
phone and called the cops and they
automatically when they seen me gave
them a felony battery
and this the he had beat me like four
days before though so you know the
bruises kind of sunk in a little bit
still enough they still
gave him felony battery like I was
bleeding from the inside hey he messed
me up really bad I'm still messed up
from that like physically or he kicked
me like 100 times
any word you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
that
if you're not there for yourself no one
else is going to be
that you are the one that has that
you're the one that puts your life into
existence and
you're the one that has to make sure
things get done you know what I'm saying
because like I said I was kind of raised
by my grandma a little bit and stuff
like that so I always have someone take
care of me I always had and even my
husband my ex-husband now
um he always took care of me I was there
for me whatever I needed but well and
now that I'm out here alone it's a
really hard world to be alone out here
and especially
someone who is
that you know I didn't
I didn't ever think that I would have to
spend my life alone but that's the way
it's been for the past
no one don't I guess people don't like
me some guys don't like I mean I guess
they wouldn't try to [__] me or whatever
I don't get down like that you know I'm
not gonna sit there and let you just
screw me unless you got some money
you know
and now I'm not going below 60. and
these people don't like that so I can't
help them because
um it's not free you know you're just
gonna [__] me I'm sorry not unless
you're my my man
not unless I'm with you you know what
I'm saying then that's different but I
don't even know these people and you
gotta have a condom
or you're not touching me
and that's a that's a fact no no not
without a condom ever
because I've been down that road too
called don't call the STD and now I'm
looking like a fool out here
so I take all that medicine and stuff
and it's just I felt very degraded very
just nasty now I do still feel that way
no matter how many times I pay I could
sit in that shower for a month and I
still feel disgusting
because of what I've done too
myself like there's my arm right here
this is from shooting up like a week ago
whatever your arm is dead
I shot up some heroin
and um
oh arm like this one I can't do that to
the sand
it's dead now
and that's for me being as long as I've
been going on this just happened like a
week ago
a week or so ago
I don't know if I had like a little
stroke or something
for my arm to be like that because I've
been man I've been a junkie
well Jordan is
24. so
probably 20 years I've been doing my
thing and nothing like ever happened you
know like right now I'm touching my arm
it's just tingling my protein goes all
in my arm
so
but I'm trying to I got this little
thing that I squeeze some little squeeze
balls you know those
um or they call them stress relievers
I got one of them that I'm using to try
to um work my um I guess my muscle back
right whatever
but
now I can be a real [__] because if my
hand's already like [__]
but
I don't know
we've had a rough ride yeah
hey but
if if I'm glad I went through a lot of
the things I've been through because I
can tell my child my children about it
and hopefully they'll listen that
um
what's good and what's bad because
like my 24 year old she's a hot mess but
um she usually listens to me you know
what I'm saying she usually whatever I
say she does
so
and
I know she's not out there
doing
prostituting and messing around and
doing stuff like that you know what I
mean and I would never I hope my kids
don't watch
you know what I'm saying on YouTube or
nothing like that because I don't want
them to be
or the people around them to put them
down or nothing like that because
um of what I'm saying and
because my children are not me
and they are have their own life
and they make their own decisions and
that's why one reason why I'm here and
you're there so they don't have to see
this or hear this
nothing about their mom being on the
streets or being a hoe or or shooting up
or
anything you know what I'm saying
because they don't know nothing about it
so that's another reason why I kind of
stayed
because they they kind of mess with my
kid about me
being who being what I do and stuff
because I mean that's just something
that's been happening for a really long
time like since 20 years now
all right Amy thank you so much for
sharing your story